his weight of the belt is gonna be
through his wrestling I hate when these
top level Grapplers and wrestlers fall
in love with striking yeah I think that
Bo won't be that guy he's too smart with
the squad and the team he has around him
to not use his wrestling so with that
crew one I see that being a huge
Advantage for him because he listens to
his leaders he's not making his own Camp
he's not running his own show that's a
huge huge thing for him they're not
giving him fights and this is how I came
up in my career when I always had a rule
where I would just the rule was as long
as they don't have three fights more
than me and experience I guarantee you
all beat their ass because it's the
experience that matters uh because of
the athlete that I am is how my mindset
works I know for him he's not getting
booked with guys more than three fights
and then that means that this person
that he's fighting regardless of any
tool set that they have doesn't have any
more experience than him so it's hard to
beat somebody like an athlete like Bo
Nick